pour ne louper aucune vidéo abonnez-vous
et activer la petite cloche salue les
épis curieux pourquoi dit-on donner sa
langue au chat
vous n'avez pas la réponse je vous
explique tout
[Musique]
donner sa langue au chat on l'a tous
fait quand on n'a pas la réponse à une
question sur l'origine de cette
expression par exemple je suis sûr que
certains donnent leur langue au chat
elle remonte au 19e siècle à une époque
où le chat était considéré comme un
confident celui à qui on glissait dé
secret dans le creux de l'oreille des
choses qu'ils ne devaient pas être
répétée des choses que les autres ne
devait pas savoir donner sa langue au
chat
c'est donc faire appel à lui pour qu'il
nous révèle les choses que lui sait est
que nous ne savons pas à très bientôt on
se retrouve très vite sur ma chaîne et
sur les réseaux si vous avez aimé cette
vidéo n'hésitez pas à laisser un pouce
bleus merci les épis curieux pour les
plus gourmands
en voici d'autres et pour ne rien rater
abonnez vous et activer la cloche
[Musique]